there's people starving there's people
with no jobs
that's the crisis in this state not
animals running at large it was a jungle
out there
lions and tigers monkeys and bears it's
a scene out of a far-fetched horror film
the death toll was staggering an
inexplicable one man and 50 exotic
animals in 2011 Ohio exotic animal owner
Terry Thompson committed suicide after
sending his animals loose no civilians
were injured but law enforcement killed
many of the escaped animals people
clamored for action and the state
responded by introducing the dangerous
animal act in a record time placing
restrictions on owning and caring for
all sorts of animals from reptiles to
primates to focus on this and this law
as fast as they did and to pass it as
fast as they did was nothing but a
knee-jerk reaction cindy huntsman is the
president of stumphill farm in Massillon
Ohio Cindy and a few other exotic animal
owners sued the state over the law and
after a long appeals process the court
ruled to maintain the act in March of
2014 the Ohio Department of Agriculture
commented we are pleased with the
court's decision - once again I pulled
the constitutionality of this law we
hope this question has now been firmly
laid to rest and that the state can move
forward with continuing our enforcement
of these safety and care regulations for
dangerous wild animals we've got a real
problem with legislation in response to
a crisis being rammed through because
oftentimes its hastily done it's poorly
done and it does not respect individual
rights what happened in Zanesville was
an isolated incident despite the
proliferate ownership of these wild
animals in Ohio for all of these years
that was the only incident than anybody
could point to one incident in you know
200 plus years of Ohio history attorney
Maurice Thompson has been keeping an eye
on the act since it was first introduced
and says that while it's
well-intentioned it's overkill you can
think of it kind of like this like if
you're going to have wild animals in
Ohio you basically need to have like the
equivalent of a maximum-security prison
like walls that are so high you need to
have a minimum two acre a lot no matter
what kind of an animal it is it could be
for monkeys and you still need a two
acre a lot the same size applies to a
monkey that would apply to a tiger or
rhinoceros the new requirements are not
what I call in the best interest of the
animal for instance raising our cages to
twelve foot with the snow and the ice
that we've had this winter all it does
is make our cages weaker and make them
more susceptible to cave-ins Huntsman
adds that aside from these regulations
not being effective they're also very
difficult to comply with for individuals
who have had animals or owned animals
that are on that dangerous wild animal
band it's very hard for them trying to
get insurance has been the most
exhausting for everyone then trying to
meet the cage requirements trying to
meet the requirements that the state
wants for veterinary care it's very
taxing for the individual it's cost us
over seventy thousand dollars
because owners dedicate their lives to
taking care of these animals Thompson
says they have more expertise than
lawmakers you may say well it's unsafe
to own these animals well the owners
have been approved through all kinds of
federal accreditation programs but what
Ohio has said is that the federal
accreditations aren't good enough but
the Ohio Department of Agriculture told
reason that the federal qualifications
and requirements are too loose and don't
properly manage the ownership of the
animals but if the state's new
regulations are too rigid
there aren't many options left some
owners are seeking refuge at sanctuaries
like stump Hill for their animals like
my aunt she came to us about four months
ago people had her as a pet she was very
well cared for they just couldn't meet
the requirements that the state had set
forth for them so they surrendered her
here but one sanctuaries reach capacity
owners who can comply will be forced to
surrender their animals to state
facilities the Department of Agriculture
says these facilities are for holding
the animals until they can find a better
home but that's not how the owners have
interpreted it the law doesn't allow for
anything else but to euthanize them
in the animal industry called the new
building that they built and
Reynoldsburg the death chamber it's too
early to tell what will actually happen
to the animals but in balancing what's
best for the animals with public safety
needs Thompson says the new regulations
missed the mark so how can we properly
protect society from these potential
escapes if the animals cause harm or if
the animals are even loose and roaming
the streets then you throw the book at
these people but like many things in
society you have to understand that
there's that punishment or the prospect
of punishment has a deterrent effect
that will cause people to be more
careful and how they conduct themselves
and you have to rely upon the court
system rather than over-the-top in your
face and beforehand regulations to
accomplish these goals I've always felt
that people are entitled to their choice
of pets as long as they can maintain
them and they the animals that we've
gotten in that have been surrendered to
us because of this new bill have been
well cared for